[Musique]
pas celle à ce genre de bêtises en ont
tu vois toi mon gars tu attends promu
il ya problème il faut partir dit
c'était trop dangereux
l'histoire
vous allez me jurez que jamais
vous direz acquise de l'if3 missiles
tous des juifs faite et puis ça a été
j'ai flashé juive
[Musique]
que dire de la vie parce qu'on a peur
d'en prendre
[Musique]
ça y est on était parti
prix libre on l'avait jamais dit tu es
qui pue des pieds forte où tu pue du cul
je t'apporterai jusqu'au bout du monde
s'il le fallait
tout le monde avait peur
même si tous sont blancs
on a fini par oublier confier quelque
chose
tu me voir je ne peux pas rester à
santos et il faut regarder devant la
main tu peux te retrouver
[Musique]
pouey
personne ne te reste pas on s'en sortira
jamais du poids sera ponctuée de
l'espoir qu'ils à frire
dire interdit tenir si tu continues à te
battre
à mirta lycée danton breux comme ça tu
as ta santé
[Musique]